talk a little bit about uh if if having
David star in your show is like having a
cheat code in a video
game well uh I think you just hit the
hit the nail on the head um you know
David O
Yello uh his talent is only surpassed by
his
Humanity so you you get the best of both
worlds you get
an actor whose ability is
transcendent and then you get a
collaborator who whose Grace makes you
feel comfortable and and and welcomed at
every single turn um he's he's truly a
remarkable human being was that $5 or
$10 for you to say that that he gave you
neither neither I I uh I he embarrasses
me and I embarrass him and it's it's not
intentional but it's it's genuinely how
I feel um you know I've had a lot of
great collaborations in this business
but uh his is his is the one that uh I
value the most at this stage of my
career yeah I've spoken to him a number
of times he's also just a super nice guy
lovely human lovely human the series is
Eight Episodes and I'm curious how did
you guys find that number was it ever
going to be 10 was it ever going to be
six was it Paramount plus saying we want
eight like how did that get figured out
there were many conversations about uh
how many
episodes we were going to tell you know
at the end of the day Paramount asked
for eight and I felt like we could
deliver eight in a satisfying way and so
that's how we ended with eight so one of
the things about his life is it's filled
with so many moments that would be great
for television so how did you figure out
wait a minute what are we going to be
cutting out here because we're only
doing this in one season yeah I mean so
there there are those Touchstone moments
that we sort of know um you know uh I
I wanted to leave some meat on the bone
in case there there was an appetite for
more bass
Reeves um so for us it
was taking those seminal moments we know
about his life from you know roughly
1862 to
1877 and using those as pillars
to build the narrative off of um and and
really trying to honor those stories
that are often told and then fill in the
in between with um some fiction that
created a satisfying narrative yeah that
was actually something that surprised me
was uh Paramount announced that it was
going to be an anthology series uh you
know the law man series and I was
thinking what if this is like a big hit
because everything Taylor touches tends
to do really well you know anything that
has his name on it somehow so I was just
wondering but I guess you've answered it
like you've only gone to n to
1877 in case they decide they want to do
more well I mean for us we felt like we
could tell a satisfying version of bass
re's life in that in that time period
and should there be an appetite for more
again there there there is more on the
bone should there be an appetite for um
a different law law man um I'm I'm
excited by that opportunity as well
there's a handful of stories that I'd
love to tell none of which I'm willing
to share right now but uh definitely um
you know I think either path would be a
great one one of the things that I think
resonates with audiences is how much uh
Taylor's produced shows um film on
location and feel like they're authentic
and it's not just all Sound Stage work
but it also is incredibly tough on the
cast and crew being on location and
Outdoors for so much of the shoot can
you talk about some of those challenges
that come with making a show like this
definitely the toughest production that
I've ever been a part of
um any challenge that you've heard of we
probably experienced I mean we got shut
down for a week and a half because of an
ice
storm um we had some locations that were
a three-hour
Drive um you know working in Texas from
January through may you deal with
extreme cold you deal with extreme
heat um and again in order to have the
authenticity that we needed we would
find places that were removed from any
sense of modernity so you know we didn't
have any Creature Comforts that t
typically accompany a show of this
size so it is hard but at the same time
it was worth it to try to capture as an
authentic of a place and a time as we
could well I think that's one of the
reasons why I I mean I I've seen the
first three episodes and I would watch
four through eight if Paramount had sent
them to me you know um so where are you
in the edit are you done with the all
eight or are you still cutting we're
almost done we're almost done we're
we're we're we we're wrapping up the
last two so how has the show changed in
the editing room in ways you didn't
expect going in it's an interesting
question um
you know you as you edit you
find things
that um scream louder if you will um
than they did on the page and you find
things that don't scream quite as loud
as you
anticipated um and so it's really trying
to
mine uh the best story based on the
footage that you have which is based on
the scripts that we wrote um you know
one thing that
I was hopeful for and I think that we
really achieved and I saw it in post was
this notion of the Triumph of the human
Spirit um and something that uh we were
able to really um Elevate through
editorial what do you think would
surprise soon to be fans of the series
to learn about the making of the series
that we all got
along that that you know despite the
hardships that come with making a show
like this um the level of camaraderie
and the dedication to honoring bass
Reeves's
Legacy permeated through every
Department um and again aside from David
made other lifelong friendships that I
will cherish forever I'm curious if you
talk a little bit about uh with Taylor
Sheridan he really does have a a sense
of what people will respond to can you
talk a a little bit about how involved
he was uh in the production slost
production like where he could sprinkle
his knowledge or how he helped bring
this to life yeah he has a a god-given
gift for storytelling um so in the
scripting phase you know he would be
able to point to a moment in a script
that I or another writer wrote and say
you know if you if you put this tiny
little moment right here
here the idea that you're trying to get
across will really make the story sing
louder um and so that was invaluable in
scripting um during production you know
as I've alluded to you know he built
this machine that makes these shows and
so was able
to you know say hire this ad she's
phenomenal and you know we did and she
was was phenomenal or his g& crew or his
Wranglers which I mean these these men
and
women their talent is unbelievable and
it's incredible and what they can do
with horses and how they can train
actors to ride horses it's incredible
and then post it's more that magic dust
that he has with let's let's mine this
part of the story a little bit more uh
to really to really make the episode
sing and so you know again he has his
god-given ability to look at a story and
improve on it and dissect it and all
those things but I will say that I'm
also very grateful for him because he
empowered me gave me a ton of autonomy
um to use a a football metaphor let me
pick up a football and run with it
so so for that I'm grateful on that note
I got to stop I'm just going to say when
they send me episodes four through eight
I will push play and on that note um
have a fantastic day thank you that's
awesome here I really appreciate
it